we're told to study the growth of
bacteria a scientist measures the area
in square millimeters occupied by a
sample population the growth of the
population can be modeled by F of T is
equal to 24 times e to the 0.4 times T
power where T is a number of hours since
the experiment began here's the graph of
F so I'm guess is going to be the output
of this function is going to be the
number of square millimeters after T
hours alright so here we have the graph
we see how as time goes on the square
millimeters of our little bacterial
population keeps growing and it clearly
is growing or it looks like it's growing
exponentially in fact we know it's going
exponential because it's an exponential
function right over here and they say
when does the population first occupy an
area of 400 square millimeters so pause
this video and try to figure that out
all right and this is a screenshot from
the Khan Academy exercise so we want to
say when does the population first
occupy an area of 400 square millimeters
let's see 400 square millimeters is
right over there
and so it looks like after seven hours
that we are going to be 400 square
millimeters or larger so it first hits
it after seven hours so seven hours just
like that now let's do the next few
examples that build on this so if I go
back up to the top and now we're told
the same thing we're using square
millimeters square millimeters to study
the growth this is the function but then
they add this next line here is the
graph here is the graph of F and the
graph of the line y equals 600 so they
added that graph there and then they say
which statement represents the meaning
of the intersection point of the graphs
all right so let's look at the choices
here so and it says choose all that
apply so pause this video and see if you
can answer that
all right so choice a
says it describes the time when the
population occupies 600 square
millimeters so which statement
represents the meaning of the
intersection point of the graph so
they're talking about they're talking
about this point right over there
so does that describe the time when the
population occupies 600 square
millimeters so that is the time when the
population has indeed reached 600 square
millimeters because that's the line y is
equal to 600 square millimeters so I
like that choice I will select it the
next choice it gives the solution to the
equation 24 times e to the 0.40 is equal
to 600 well if you think about it this
right over here in blue we've already
talked about it that is y is equal to 24
times e to the 0.40 power this is y is
equal to 600 so the T value at which
these two graphs equal that means that
they're both equal to the same y value
or another way to think about it it
means that that is equal to that or that
24 times e to the 0.40 power is indeed
equal to 600 so I like this too it gives
a T value where this is true so that's
the solution to that equation
it describes the situation where the air
where the area the population occupies
is equal to the number of hours that's
definitely not the case because the area
here is 600 square millimeters the hours
looks like it's a little bit after 8 so
they're definitely not equal
it describes the area the population
occupies after 600 hours no we don't
have to look up there this t axis
doesn't even go to 600 hours so we
wouldn't select that as well now let's
keep building and go to the next part of
this and it says it says so once again
we measure the area square millimeters
to figure out the growth of the
population the
of us here we have two populations here
it says the growth of population a can
be modeled by F of T is equal to that
we've seen that already but now they are
introducing another population the
growth of population B can be modeled by
G of T is equal to this where T is the
number of hours since the experiment
began here are the graphs of F and G so
now we have two populations they're both
growing exponentially but at different
rates and then it says when do the
populations occupy the same area and
says round your answer to the nearest
integer and you could pause this video
and try to think about that if you like
well you can see very clearly that it
looks like or they intersect right
around there so that's the point in
which they're going to occupy the same
area it looks like it's about a hundred
and seventy five square millimeters but
they're not asking about the area
they're saying when does it happen and
it looks like it happens after about
five hours so round to the nearest
integer let's say five hours now let's
do the last part so it's the same set up
but now they are asking us a different
question they are asking us which
statements represent the meaning of the
intersection points of the graphs all
right
so choice a it says and then pause the
video again and try to answer these on
your own
all right choice a says it means that
the populations both occupied about a
hundred eighty square millimeters at the
same time so let's see this that looks
about right I had estimated 175 but you
could call that 180 and it looks like
that does roughly happen at around the
fifth hour so it looks like they're
occupying the same area at around the
same time so I like that choice it means
that at the beginning population a was
larger than population B well the point
of intersection is doesn't tell us what
population was larger to begin with we
could try to answer it by looking over
here when time T equals zero when time T
equals zero population a is the blue
curve it is F and so it does look like
population a was larger than population
B at time
equals zero at the beginning but that's
not what the point of intersection tells
us so they're not just asking us for
true statements they're saying which
statements represent the meaning the
meaning of the intersection point of the
graphs but that doesn't tell us about
what the starting situation was it gives
a solution to the equation 24 times e to
the 0.40 is equal to 9 times e to the
0.60 well we already talked about that
in the in the last example we really had
one curve and that actually is the case
because Y is equal to 24 times e to the
zero point 4 T is the curve for
population a and then y is equal to 9
times e to the zero point six T is the
curve for population B and so the point
at which these two curves intersect
that's the point at which both this
we're at a T value that gives the same
so that this expression will give you
the same y value as this expression or
another way to say it is we're at the T
value where this is equal to this so it
does indeed give us a solution to the
equation and then the last choice is it
gives the solution to the equation 24
times e to the 0.40 is equal to 0
no that would happen if you want to know
when it's equal to 0 you would look at
the curve y equals 0 I'll do that in a
different color which is right over here
and see where it intersects the function
f which is equal to 24 times e to the
0.40 but that's not what this point of
intersection represents so we definitely
wouldn't pick that one either